[Music]
[Music]
is that New York abacus
here baby I am Josh Salette and this is
the 2019 Marvel contest of Champions
ultimate fighters
at the Kabam booth at five five six
we've had people competing thursday
friday and today to be here on this
stage live but i cannot do this by
myself so please give a huge welcome to
dorky dignity dave and tyler nikka
[Applause]
gentlemen welcome welcome welcome
Nikki thank you very hello you've seen
the best of the best compete on that
stage but now who else is left who else
will defeat them who can compete against
these players look Oh what is this
are we late in the semi it is the
champion oh my goodness
it's an absolutely devastating kit we've
got on this I got to tell you man you're
gonna have to upgrade your mugs because
the tears will not be tiny for this
battle right here so break this down for
me both of you
give us some like information on
regarding the champion what do these
players will be learning board should we
go lower first goal or first we're gonna
go lower first so anyone who has played
act six chapter two of Marvel contest of
Champions will be familiar with the
champion himself now in an attempt to
assert dominance over the collector and
his daughter Karina the Grandmaster has
given a power stone to the champion
you're gonna be seeing that right here
on the champions forehead he's got a
tricky tool kit you're gonna need swift
reflexes careful avoidance because this
is the fallen one he is the cream of the
crop we will rise to the top you are
gonna have to use everything you can to
bring him down dorks got the stats hard
look I gotta tell you man there are
certain there are certain figures that
can walk on water this guy walks on
tears yeah this is what he walks on I
gotta tell you he's got 100% champion
boost which means his attack and health
is already boosted 300% health boost he
can he'll block and he has a special
three that you do not want to activate
he's got a long list of stuff going on
here I'm just gonna go down some of the
more important ones oh under 70% if he's
unstoppable and you try to attack him
he's going to stun you back you gotta
watch out for that under 40% all medium
attacks are unblockable you cannot block
them you cannot parry you got to be very
very smart about that out of the way
absolutely the last 10% is the one that
everyone knows the best he has five
charges indestructible charges the only
way you can get rid of them is by
gaining a prowess by deque seeing a
special you cannot damage him you have
two decks a special five times and then
you can take him down you know he can
glow he can smack down he can take you
from the top ropes this is your ultimate
challenge this weekend oh my
gosh alright guys so the rules yes give
it a shadow yeah give it up give it up
give it up each competitor will get a
chance to compete to take him down the
person who does it the quickest will win
however if no one defeats him we will
have a rematch to see if they can defeat
the champion now if they all cannot
defeat him after that then it's the
person who's on the most damage to the
champion all right so we might see some
rematches we might see a rematch now
what do they win what do they win will
surely show win they're gonna be hitting
themselves close the charges it is
gorgeous you also will receive a
six-star guillotine $20.99 a six-star
generic awakening gem and an exclusive
in the game title and obviously some
bragging rights absolutely so should we
should we bring them on stage bring them
on do you wanna see the three elites
summoners you guys want to see them see
them compete please welcome to the stage
Thursday's winner dreamin sucks come on
down come on Friday and today's winner
metal sonic dude come on down come on
down gentlemen come on down just follow
him kavorka board all right so I think
all three of you your first time on the
stage correct second time on this oh
yeah remember remember how does it feel
to be here to compete for this challenge
very nervous I wish I practice a little
more before coming on here and wish I
did 6.1 before doing this all right
scene you are no stranger to this game
so what does it feel to be on this stage
is a pleasure I am just thrilled to be
here man I'm gonna do the best I can
today see what happens
oh yeah all right Metal Sonic dude
second time you're on the stage you're
no stranger how you feeling I'm feeling
right man time to take down champion you
are the only one who defeated nameless
Thanos at the Kabam booth do you think
they're nervous maybe a little bit are
you guys nervous for that you won't be
mad you've got B this kid's got skills
look at I love that I love that all
right guys one winner the two others
will go home and receive tiny mugs for
their tiny oh they know what's up they
know what's up
all right gentlemen please exit stage
right so oh no not exit just kidding
stay on stage we're gonna see the order
and wish they compete in so they are
tiny mugs for your tiny tiny marks we're
tight in here with numbers 1 2 & 3 the
order of which you will be competing in
all right number three number one oh I
wonder what it could be
just know that you can keep those mugs
if you want you know we're gonna keep
them no you don't give them nobody
wanted them all right all right
gentlemen so the player won please stay
up all the rest exit stage right you
gotta set the bar high my friend do you
know who you want to choose um I think
so
what wall the notes what the notes
should we give him the note this is
exactly like six point two I think I'm
gonna go for stealth suit spider-man
that is so there's there's two very
great choices in my opinion I think
spider-gwen is a better one but stealth
suit Spidey can also do it you got to be
careful about that 70% light attacks are
unblockable so if you're just standing
there trying to parry you might get
combo to oblivion
all right see let's see how you do
please take your seats and go ahead and
choose your champion y'all fixing can do
this alright y'all seen good luck good
luck good luck
alright now he's gonna go far from home
and we're gonna see if that brings him
close to victory now still stood
spider-man also has a slow debuff
mechanic which is going to allow him to
get around those UNSTOPABLES that
seemingly come around at random but they
really come around every 13 seconds but
because he has persistent charges they
are sped up to
60% faster so we're gonna be seeing a
lot more of those UNSTOPABLES coming
through he's gonna read that on he's
adding that he's adding that wet foam
make sure that he adds that slow debuff
and we're gonna see how well he does
that keeping in mind what isn't
unstoppable and what isn't at what
percentage is going to be a very hard
challenge because here you don't get the
break like you do with nameless Thanos
you just have to keep an eye on the
health bar now and taking a quick scan
through those buffs because reading is
of course fundamental all right Seaton
are you ready ready as I'll ever be
three two one
all right now he said he was bringing in
spider-man but I'm only see a night
monkey on the screen here yes we have
stealth suit spider-man in here now he
does have evade ability which is a
reliable one and he's gonna go in and
put that slow debuff right away so that
he does not gain that unstoppable this
is going to give him a lot of benefit
here because he can just attack him and
getting out of the way of his special
attacks is relatively easy
there aren't any projectiles or anything
like that so he's gonna go ahead and
start placing the hurt there is a SP two
right there he's out of the way he goes
right back in he's going to finish it
off with that lighted with that light
attack he's got two more charges left to
keep on adding that slow debuff let's
see how well he does from here he takes
a few hits to the face those are really
going to hurt he is now below 70% he
cannot take any hits by light attacks
and he has unstoppable and he is
retaining at this point that stealth is
not coming in handy he's seeing him on
every move he cannot hit him at this
point he's going to return none and it's
just that fast when you're standing
against one of the elders come up here
see him come up here great job give it
up for seed and give it over scene this
is not easy y'all this is not easy if
you could have done this again you still
might have a chance to do this again
would you stick with the same champion
definitely it was just that special too
if they're connected it would have given
me the slow I needed to get back into
the
fight so it is what it is do have any
words for your summoners coming up
that's the luck all right all right give
it up for seeing one more time our next
challenger dreaming sucks come on to the
stage oh no oh he's he's right over to
the pad you can't be stopped absolutely
yeah you got a fan base so are you gonna
stick with the same champion that Seaton
chose yep oh you're not nervous that
what he just did on yeah no not nervous
at all all right you think do you think
you can defeat the champion
supersymmetry take your seat see me out
Supremes Dave still thinks spider-gwen
is the way to go there's something very
valuable about enervates and not having
power gain and paralyzed and also having
slow with a heavy attack you have much
more control over the flights
what's symbionts supreme we'll be fine
no Simula supreme one of my favorites an
original character to the contest that
is an amalgamation of one of the Clint
our symbiotes with dr. strange when you
get those necromancy powers it's hard to
go wrong that's right now when he goes
below 40% one of the bad things about
Sevilla supreme is if he adds a stagger
and he nullifies he's going to take 10%
of the champions damage direct so you
gotta be careful about that but he does
have to beat the last set of damage so
let's just see what happens all right
well he's got a good amount of audience
members rooting for him will he go out
with a nice Oh sphere trophy or will I
go out with tiny mud for your tiny all
right three two one fight all right by
the hoary hosts of Horus here we go he
goes on in he's going to get his first
amounts of damage in he got a staggering
so he's hopefully going to block that
unstoppable which is a pain for this
fight now many people have beaten the
champion with Sam supreme he's got those
first combos in he's waiting for his
first SP one but I think he's going to
wait till he gets over to the ESPYs
three so he can start doing some major
bleep damage and he goes for the sp2
instead he has now we have champion with
his sp2 ready to go he just has to paint
it out so he can get back in and do the
business
those nullifies early on or helping him
avoid that unstoppable but he takes a
combo to the face and he gets him up to
sp3 this looks like this is going to be
over it's hard to avoid that running arm
when it's coming at you and he must
every code fireworks for the champion
fireworks for the champion yes or the
funeral whichever one you want to call
it do you think your fans let you down
the wrong path or scindia supreme no
they would never
Deepti you and let them Taylor's led me
down the right path I'm just a scrub you
made it up here you were no scrub you
made it to the stage what could you have
done differently
done Sixpoint to hilarious guys give it
up for Dreeben sucks if you want those
sweet careful your bonuses you need to
go up against the heart opponents
absolutely we got one more summoner
let's see it
metal sonic do
[Music]
dude you got a great name to just shout
out to the to the world I gotta say
alright both of those players did not
defeat the champion you could right now
win it if you can defeat him do you
think you do it maybe well champion
she-hulk she crowd favorites no problems
with that laying down the law with she
home I have no problem with that I'm
excited to see you you have no problems
with that you have Dave's blessing yay
yeah all right guys take a seat will he
go home with the ISO sphere don't really
go home
with a tiny mug for it's tidy come on
guys you do better than that you know
you can do all right
she-hulk a personal favorite of mine and
for those I hold close I am very excited
about this matchup Dave absolutely
please this is going to be an exciting
matchup now she has changed just a
little bit but I think she can still do
it
wait did he just put up spider-gwen
she-hulk looking surprisingly like Gwen
Stacy that was just a little bit
different color they're tricking us yeah
we're good we're green it's the mean
green fightin machine alright he could
send them all home right now with tiny
moat for the tiny tears are you guys
ready to see Metal Sonic dude are you
guys ready to see this will count off
with me oh I'll wait for him to read
he's reading it still reading I mean
again oh you already heard Intel
research all right gets in that Mary
right at the beginning goes in with a
heavy attack and he's gonna you're gonna
be seeing a lot of those heavy attacks
to get up against that unstoppable so
that he can place the slow debuff he
gets in us he gets in a great combo goes
in with another heavy attack gets
another slow on there this way you see
primal fury is showing up but you see no
unstoppable going along with it so he is
expertly placing those heavy attacks
gets an sp2 loaded up
he's got this down he's got this down
he's going for the sp3 instead it looks
like now she-hulk matches that brain and
brawn and we were seeing that
represented here oh he knows how to do
this let's get it done let's see what
he's got in the buckets now these heavy
attacks he's just laying them on one
after the other he cannot get
unstoppable while he is slowed down and
this is actually going to be a pretty
important part of the fight and it seems
like he's got a mastery of this spike
down he's down to 70% so we are now in
the new section at this point light
attacks are unblockable and he has just
gone for it he's not even bothering with
his sb3 he's just landing it and taking
it taking it down this is impressive to
watch we are down to 58% our next setup
is going to be at 40% where mediums are
unblockable we are almost there
absolutely astounding effort here he is
knocking it out those are the intercepts
are on point it looks like he is not
even trying gets in a five-hit combo
launches that he's got him down to 31%
make him without even trying showing
everybody how it's done there's another
every attack we are now into the last
10% he takes the block damage gets his
first oh he's almost he's gonna he's
gonna nail you're gonna have a
class-action suit after that right now
he's got those he's got those five he's
got those five charges he has got to
take off
he just got hit with a special but he's
still in there getting those intercepts
he needs to get those five prowess to
get this thing done now he's at the SB
one got what Brauer is one out of five M
he needs four more bills in order to get
this done just holding on to that SP
three to lay this down we've got two
minutes 13 seconds we're down to three
that is down he's got deulim three more
to go
built up to the SP one he's got 13%
health left
absolutely top level category two more
to go that is insanity they said they
couldn't be done they sure that
shouldn't be done and here we are
absolutely amazing taking the knee I
mean we still have 12 minutes left
you're gonna ask him to relive every
moment of that win to your fans
how does it feel I can't feel my heart
right now but not only did you defeat
the champion in 3 minutes and 12 seconds
you knocked off two of the summoner's
the elite summoners of this week you're
going home with the ISOs fear you are
the New York Comic Con champion of
merica
[Music]
that is to chaos in one day the only one
to do it in this competition that is
absolutely nuts e's shown that he has
the skill he has the mastery of the game
and he is the one to beat next year
absolutely I'm shaking I have no voice
left like so you can't feel your heart
hopefully you can cuz you're still alive
alright well you gotta carry the trophy
go get that trophy get your photos get
your photos get your photos I mean how
you guys feeling I am out of words and
that's the main part of my job I'm
absolutely astounded that's a very tough
fight to do especially to get the five
charges at the end and the way that he
got them he knew exactly what he's doing
he looks like he literally just finished
that yesterday doing it like ten million
times came in mastered it got it down he
just had the muscle memory has a skill
absolutely when you when you're playing
it at this level it is a whole different
game you can play for the story you can
play for the champions or you can play
for absolute glory as we're seeing here
today I was talking to Gabe and Vince
earlier and they said nobody will be
able to defeat the champion they told me
that yes and yet right here we have we
had Lee let me tell you man a lot of
people had a hard time with this at home
by themselves in their own room with
nobody watching he came up here on stage
with all these people watching and
knocked it out like it was nothing as
we've seen today if you want to take
down a macho man you bring the Hulkster
to the fight yes all right
oh if we ever do summoner showdown ever
again you better be there because I want
to see that happen all right
final words to all your fans what are
you gonna say thanks to my dad for
taking me here you're the friend best
and thanks for the whole community for
taking me in at 15 I mean that's that's
pretty awesome and thanks for everyone
cheering man you guys are awesome
alright we got some time left so I want
to bring up dreaming sucks and seaton
one more time to get all three of these
guys up here let's make them realize our
round of applause for the final three of
this week the camaraderie is awesome yes
give it up cheating dreamin you know
what you guys get to win tiny tear tiny
mugs for your tiny there you go my
friend you go my friend
all right we'll get in there in the
middle oh you get to get the trophy
put them up yes guys is Marvel contest
of Champions go to their booth at
commands booth at five five six to
checkout Marvel realm of Champions and
pledge your house you guys can play this
game right now it's insane